[Musique]
et du taux voudrait déjà rendu des
constats roger déjà rempli et constatent
alors vous allez remplir mon constat
alors pourquoi j'ai un accident va mais
quand ça tout à l'heure tout ça en
venant ici mais grave
la tôle froissée penser comment dans la
tête de lugano est pour l'adulte à des
présidentielles à ce point là à ce point
là oui autrement dit la voiture est
foutue a complètement foutue reste plus
rien de la voiture
ainsi quoi le constat mais vous vous
n'avez rien j'ai un léger traumatisme
crânien ou ça ne nous fait une radio
poivrière pelle dans les grosses têtes
mais ça s'est passé commente accidents
laa aux vêtements je voulais
tranquillement marche arrière à 180 leur
dans un sens interdit pour aller me
reprenne notre dame devant la caserne de
pompiers quand j'ai heurté un convoi
exceptionnel qui viennent ma droite puis
je vous posais une question d'en
proposer vous avez votre permis de
conduire
bien oui j'ai mon permis de conduire il
fait passer avec un inspecteur avec un
inspecteur est toujours en vie bien sûr
il vient de terminer sa rééducation
bon alors dit dont la roue à gauche
lâche étape qu'est ce qu'un chemin et la
date de l'accident basse aujourd'hui
alors mettez aujourd'hui mais ça tient
pas alors métayère bon le lieu le lieu
la neige la neige qu'elle 9 bat la nef
de notre dame
mais qu'est ce que vous faisiez dans la
verve de notre dame va c'est là où j'ai
été projeté par convoi exceptionnel dans
la nef dans la nes
mon dieu avis et scali l'archevêque
envoyés entre les indiens
alors maintenant je vais me tenait bon
alors blessé même léger qu'est ce qu'un
des blessés
à ma connaissance non et l'autre
conducteur il est sans connaissance à
face mais non il vit seul à tous les
témoins les témoins et des témoins il ya
des témoins qui sont ils un mariage
parfait bon véhicule à véhicule b vous
êtes à aubes et ce n'est pas mon réseau
plus important recul avant d'entrer via
sa part l'importance alors là sur
l'assuré c'est moi très bien le nom
alpha le prénom remet aux alfa romeo
alfa romeo oui oui je m'appelle alfa
romeo free avait quelque chose honteuse
immigrés les yeux devant l'adresse
adresse 1 rue de la pompe à 100 ce
numéro de téléphone 306 à 106 oui c'est
tout on m'a coupé le reste ne serait pas
alors le véhicule le véhicule mais la
marque renault le type alfa romeo n'ont
cependant pas de gauche par du type du
véhicule a justement le type de véhicule
c'est moi puisque j'étais dedans
non je voulais dire peu de voitures d'un
cabriolet un break maintenant c'est à
couper numéro d'immatriculation à à
n'importe quoi rire un jeu dépensé 4
points qu'à ses 196 196 n'existe pas là
ça tombe bien ma voiture n'existe plus
alors dit dont la jouer demande aussi là
pour les sociétés d'assurance vieillesse
cause est assurée aweys l'assuré winkel
compagnie à la hugo y aille y y
qu'est ce que c'est que ça c'est
l'assurance européennes et
internationales des automobilistes ultra
chic du yémen
et ça donne envie ou y croit ça donne à
oyo y est comment écrivez-vous
automobilistes comme au torino mais sans
os à tapper et pourquoi avoir choisi une
compagnie du yémen parce que yémen ma
vie comme il l'entend
bon alors un peu plus bas un peu plus
bas
parce que j'aimais ma vie comme il
l'entend mais non je voulais dire un peu
plus bas sur le papier par avance à
sedan tonalité très bas que ceux qui
peuvent plus passer sur le papier oui
vous avez indiquée par une flèche bruce
willis
oui mais ça c'est fait ça c'est fait
eiffel à cet effet au début mais cela et
c'est qu'elle se sait que toutes ses
flèches
on vous avait été attaqué par des
indiens à la nano mais j'ai plusieurs
points sont initialement alors ils
choisiront et la voiture où est elle la
voiture de la dette dans notre dame mais
non se pare du croquis d'accident on est
pâtissier la voiture je ne sais pas
dessiner les voitures par dessiner autre
chose
ah bon tu dois avoir fait les beaux-arts
pour avoir un accident l'on sort plus
alors là ça de l est pas mal à l'aller
en un peu fort
moi je viens rabbin ari puis à la pause
yeux rené sépare les yeux c'est
l'essence
ah bon mais les yeux aux antilles en
approche et pour décider les yeux les
coiffes et des lunettes parce que je ne
sais pas dessiner soutien gorge adacore
bondé quand apparente
a batu sauf l'allume-cigare votre allume
cigare est intact mais ça c'est normal
pourquoi on me l'avait volé la veille un
petit tour dans les observations la
caisse que je mets ce que j'avais
ressenti ce que vous avez ressenti et
vallet que j'avais ressenti au mais non
jamais je n'oublierai ce merveilleux
hasard qui m'a permis de contempler ce
pur joyau de l'architecturé de l'art
gothique flamboyant du quatrième nom du
14ème sommet c'est dans le 4e
arrondissement à la bombe ou signés
c'est pas bien dis donc qu'est ce que
sean monde h
potash monde h non voulait dire votre
bonus mon venu / oui oui cet accident
m'a lessivée moi oui alors qu'est ce que
c'est de mon bonus ou l'échanger contre
de paquets darién bon café et ben
maintenant je voulais donner mon cou
avec d'enseignants non je suis
conseiller technique qui repoussa à la
prévention routière
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]